[Musica]
[Applauso]
quest'anno gli occhi allora che cosa
erano quelli che avete visto camicie di
forza o erano stanchi della mensa però
puliti vabbè per rispondere a questa
terra io vi faccio una domanda che è
questa
quanti momenti di umanità avete avuto
oggi per umanità non intendo con
passione che si ricordi a che età
gentilezza ma momenti di contatto umano
relazione presenza di fronte a qualcun
altro
sganciati la tecnologia da di tali vanno
su e giù da schermi qualcuno cerco di
vedere i volti o per niente
molti non chiari conti allora io vi
faccio questa domanda perché questa
domanda è un po la domanda inquisito che
attanaglia la mia vita nota un po di
anni senza dirmi sono mi sono scoperto e
ho scoperto intorno a me un
depauperamento rispetto a questa cosa
c'è
ovviamente si chiama siamo circondati
dalla tecnologia 9 questo rete di field
facile la connessione la comunicazione e
lo scambio di idee di contenuti e
quant'altro però questo rende più
difficile il leicester e presenta una
relazione sarebbe sentono relazione cosa
vuol dire avere due elementi che sono
nun di avere una presenza fisica avere
una reciproca attenzione questo è
l'interazione di lavoro su questo
abbinando che è stato sull emozione
quindi cercato di rispondere a questa
domanda io negli anni mi sono
avventurata creandomi questo strumento
surreale che sono i star di stargate
targhette emozionali e l'ho fatto
concedendo facendo teatro e diciamo
rivolgendo una nuova modalità cioè
usando il teatro in maniera non
convenzionale per lavorare sulle
relazioni all'interno delle relazioni
per osservare le emozioni che da queste
dinamiche scaturiscono io l'ho fatto
insomma gli spazi convenzionali teatri
piazze quant'altro quello che avete
visto è una performance che faccio a
milano più volte ci sono dei mostri con
questi abiti questo ambito punto di
storico molto quasi anche che crea
disagio e che si mettono in una piazza
che si mettono insomma incrocio di via e
che fanno delle domande alle persone che
passano delle domande importanti che
possono essere c'è qualcuno che ti amo
veramente piuttosto che rispettato le
regole
e quindi il fatto di portare una persona
che vedete per erano persone che a
quell'ora erano circa le 6 persone che
uscivano dall'ufficio tornavano
all'università poi eravamo proprio in
prossimità della metropolitana per cui
c'era che mi sento questo di gente e
quindi portare quelle persone stanche
insomma versi agiate la routine della
settimana della serata dell ufficio
eccetera portarle in uno spazio reale
davanti a una persona vestita da mostro
che ti chiede così don brevi cioè
qualunque notizia ma veramente comunque
una grande sfida però le persone
miracolosamente meravigliosamente
rispondono con grande generosità nel
senso che non ti insultano anche restano
lì ti rispondano con molta gentilezza e
anzi ti molto spesso ti aprono degli
scorsi molto molto interessanti molto
significativi molto commoventi anche
rispetto alle loro vite questa è la
bellezza del teatro matri emozionale
interattivo ed è funzionale interattivo
da disciplina che è stata registrata sul
registro nazionale asili bl dos
grazie a questa associazione e alle
tante bianco che è un associazione
affiliata alla lite quindi legno
internazionali diritti umani ed è per
questo che questa disciplina ha un senso
all'interno dei luoghi in cui lo lilloni
chiusi in olio di ristretti luoghi
detentivi lo in cui si lavora sulla
sulle schiaccione che diventa di
educazione forse che diventa
accompagnamento verso una guarigione da
una dipendenza
molto spesso non è così e io ho lavorato
io sono entrata per caso all'interno di
un
di una casa circondariale qualche anno
fa ha portato io una compagnia di teatro
e funzionale interattivo e siamo andati
a portare questo questo spettacolo molto
semplice che parlava parlava di una
lettera al punto che un detenuto
scriveva una a una compagna alla quale
incinta all.re in questa lettera punto
si diceva che lui probabilmente la
nascita non avrebbe visto non avrebbe
potuto vedere nascita di questo figlio
quello spettacolo venne rappresentato è
sesto secondo di san vittore per chi non
conoscesse avventore san vittore
la casa circondariale per più più belle
che abbia un titano insomma più
complessa più di milano della lombardia
diciamo ed è divisa in raggi raggiunto
da può dire a petrachi sono una sorta di
fase i gironi infernali perché sono
contenitori che vanno a chiudere delle
detenzioni diverse rispetto al reato il
senso secondo per intenderci nel raggio
dei sex offenders quindi reati a sfondo
sessuale transessuali piuttosto che
faccia insomma detenuti protetti e
quant'altro quindi per formarlo per caso
insomma quello spettacolo lì è insomma
quei detenuti ci chiedono di farlo
elaborato a chiesero di fare un
laboratorio con me
quindi quando mi fu chiesto appunto
dall'educatrice vuoi fare della tela di
educazione teatrale interattiva che
ancora non sanno sarà secondo me fatta
manco l'idea di cosa potesse essere
esattamente con questi detenuti per i
quali viene
insomma viene fatta davvero poca
formazione no il rispose di sì nel senso
che io cerco sempre di incontrare
l'altro chiunque
chi non chiunque chiunque abbia davanti
insomma senza pregiudizio senza giudizio
senza etichetta senza andare a vedere
che cosa c'è stato prima di
quell'incontro la prima che questa
persona si pone di fronte a me per quel
momento accettato e ho iniziato in era
l'era gennaio di ricordo il mio
insegnamento spazio che era un ex
infermeria adibita a diciamo statali
creativa sa insomma sarà studio sarà
prova tutto e questa ex infermeria dove
c'era vi ricordo
c'erano due sedi e c'erano un cestino
c'era un lavandino in cui transessuale
si tagliavano si facevano le mani
poi c'era questa questo finestrone alto
insomma privato di un vetero con delle
sbarre ovviamente non per cui questo
immaginate quindi di fare qualcosa di
artistico quindi che ha una finalità
anche se vogliamo così ricreativo
all'interno di uno spazio che li
ricreativo non ho niente all'interno di
una struttura gigantesca che di lì
creativamente meno all'interno punto
davanti a persone che non hanno mai
fatto teatro che non sanno che cosa
significhi quella se grandi
specificazione emozionale interattivo
per cui la prima la prima cosa è
riuscire a bordi davanti a loro insomma
chiunque in modo autentico non è
semplicemente senza filtro senza
maschera comunicando quello che sei e
in questo modo in questo in questa
maniera cercare di cercarla modalità per
condurli affascinarli e portarli verso
lungo un percorso verso la meta lamenta
che ci prefiggiamo allora io quell'anno
iniziare con 16 detenuti lo faccia tutti
uomini dai 25 65 anni etnia diversa
allora la prima cosa che ci prefiggeremo
adesso ma trovarci trovarci un nome no
perché sono dovevamo avremmo dovuto
lavorare molti mesi insieme bellissima
saremmo dovuti diventare una creatura
mobile indipendente all'interno di
quella struttura quindi molto in cui io
chiesi loro allora come ci vogliamo non
volevo chiamare questa compagnia questo
gruppo di uomini che si forma una volta
la settimana si incontra per parlare
insomma di drammaturgia vende fuori di
castino lì alla fine non è scelto questo
nome che non voglio farne parte quindi
da quel progetto non voglio farne parte
perché sostanzialmente chi lo propose di
sé chi vorrebbe fare parte di una
compagna rive tenuti che vorrebbe
entrare qui in questo spazio a fare
teatro non siano a noi in questi luoghi
quel progetto poi cammino fece suo
percorso nel senso che poi negli anni
passati senza offendersi ai reati comuni
poi passi alla circondariale di monza
attualmente sono in comunità disegno
comunità di recupero terapeutico per
tossicodipendenti alcolisti a settembre
partirà un progetto in una comunità di
minori
tornando quel non voglio in farne parte
il secondo scopo che ci prefiggiamo è
allora facciamo qualcosa di importante
qualcosa di importante però che sia in
qualche modo legato anche a quello che
abbiamo intorno a quello che come ci
sentiamo no ovviamente non posso
proporti scelsi ed un passo porti voglio
proporti qualcosa che si possa legare
alla situazione di straniamento di
solitudine che sta vivendo e la cosa
diciamo più vicina che mi venne in mente
che ci venne in mente perché realtà
c'erano all'interno due persone che
qualcosa insomma di letteratura di un
altro insomma masticano e fu godot
appunto di beckett per cui nampo e
quell'anno appunto un godot reloading di
questo spettacolo che chiamiamo la
fortuna di inserire all'interno della
giornata internazionale del teatro e
carcere dell'unesco
[Musica]
quando qualcuno mi chiede insomma di
parlare dell'esperienza del teatro e
carcere oppure anche di comunità
recentemente dico sempre per me
l'esperienza di maritano per cui per me
l'incontro era parole importantissimo la
parola meravigliosa una parola che come
una sorta di cilindro e doppi
scaturiscono mille cose bellissime no
per cui io quando entro in una struttura
detentiva che poi alla fine
pellegrinaggio perché immaginate poi
permessi corridoi e passi tra le celle
passeggiate nei corridoi tra le celle
aperte infermeria quant'altro per cui
diventa un vero pellegrinaggio perché
per chi entra e all'ostinazione di
ritornarci ogni volta per me insegnare
questo tipo di cose all'interno di
strutture di questo tipo vuol dire il
contrario vari tavoli re ritrovare
persone che la settimana dopo ti
raccontano delle storie che raccontano
che ha incontrato i figli a qui
raccontato di fare teatro e quindi figli
sono un po più contenti perché
probabilmente i genitori hanno un volto
diverso un'espressione diversa
e infatti fanno vedere delle cose delle
cose che hanno scritto che hanno provato
a scrivere quindi in qualche modo si
mette in moto una sorta di circuito di
produzione e che poi in realtà uno
scavare dentro di sé per toccare delle
cose per cui qual è il senso di tutto
quel senso di tutto questo è che io
parte ad una domanda
continuando insomma risponde rispondere
al quesito cerco di un po di stimolare
le persone che ho intorno almeno a
cercare spazi di incontro a cercare
spazi di interazione perché
nell'interazione c'è cominciamo scambio
tra due elementi c'è uno scambio anche
c'è una modifica e una trasformazione
fisiologica se vogliamo è quello che
vorrei insomma magari con l'aiuto di
giacomo provate a farvi fare una cosa
ecco questa stasera chiusura di questa
di questo breve di pizzo se magari
allora io gli chiederei quest'ultimo
supplizio l'ora di alzarvi tutti siete
molto seguiti
vi chiedo di distribuirli in modo cioè
di avvicinarmi non ci sono degli spazi
vuoti e quindi riempire le file vuote
fino ad esempio divenire insomma di
riempire tutti che viene l'impossibile
immaginabili quindi tutti quelli che
sono dietro divenire anche e quant'altro
si facciamo tre minuti tanto sono state
che voi anche chi si nasconde tra loro
quindi mancano
andiamo anche a londra go falsa falsa
falsa volontariamente rete senza paura
allora ci sta ancora qualcuno guarda
dice un posto dalla che l'asta si
annunciava un bush angolata allora te se
siete 12 45
allora facciamo così la prima fila si
gira
[Musica]
ok perfetto la terza fila siete 246 la
terza fila invece abbiamo turno della
tratta di due coppie quindi chiedo le
più note di mettersi di fronte uno di
fronte all'altro ok vuoi lavorare di
persone tutte le sere dispari invece la
terza quarta scusate numero sopra la
quarta e la quinta fila dunque la quarta
fila si gira verso la quinta fila la
nome della seconda state viste poi si
allora adesso prima fila seconda fila
portali la quinta fila avete tutti un
compagno davanti ti senti
questo c'è uno scoperto chi vuole fare
ma tu sei la sola sbadato 6 quando tu
sei con lui tu con chi stai
stasera mette ciascuno di voler avere un
compagno di fronte quindi mettetevi
secondarie
allora adesso vi chiedo di praticamente
alzare le mani
mettendo praticamente i palmi delle mani
così come le faccio io mi minore altezza
delle delle spalle e di farli avanzare
che si fame fino ad incontrare poi nelle
mani della della persona che vede di
fronte a questo punto vi chiedo di stare
lì qualche istante poi di chiudere gli
occhi
a questo punto partirà un tempo città di
tre minuti fatali semplicemente
osservate sentite disagio piacevolezza
cosi quant'altro cercate di non sentire
per quanto possibile voce la voce di chi
avete intorno a lungo nei ricordi e
concentratevi sul tasto palmi delle mani
delle persone che avete di fronte quindi
esiste soltanto ti ha ovviamente di
fronte ecco
un minuto è andato sarete ancora 2
[Musica]
però
se volete provate anche a muovere le
mani insieme all'altro invece magari
senza posizione statica vi crea fastidio
verità volete anche le mani cioè sempre
palo contro parma se lo desiderate si
ricrea un po più di benessere fisico
quello l'ultimo minuto si viene da
ridere ridete non preoccupatevi
frangente di solito scappa quando lo
sento fare
fra trenta secondi
ok potete lasciarvi slegati dalla
dall'unione sei tornate a sedervi
insomma appuntamenti e come a volte
prima
adesso volevo siccome le mie performance
incontri letrari si chiudono sempre con
quella che chiamiamo restituzione che
vuol dire condividere la roba che ha
anche un po un altro significato però
una sorta di apertura rispetto a quello
che si è sentito proprio perché si
lavora veramente poco però sulle
sensazioni fisiche eventualmente sul su
quello che si sente rispetto alla
vicinanza dell'altro
volevo chiedergli se qualcuno
volontariamente a desiderio di
condividere con con gli altri la
sensazione che ha provato se ha sentito
qualcosa può essere anche disagio schifo
insomma qualsiasi cosa c'è
le cose devono venire fuori senza senza
giudizio quindi che vengano pure parole
insomma fastidiose
solo abituando e né sentito
ciao
ma che dite sperimenta in qualcuno dello
stesso sesso
intanto nei 133 diversa rispetto al
contesto della persona citata da
stringere le mani come se fossimo un
video da qualche cosa ma da tavolo
appoggiare
[Musica]
hai mai tenuto libero
io faccio una fatica qualsiasi casta
rimuovere una cosa che si faccia anche
della quaresima
[Musica]
contrasteremo pirati io vedo un attimo
però sembra una storia più di tutte con
i propri diritti e si sa se valgono di
raccontare perché qui oggi e che cosa si
conterà un'altra delle campane che cosa
dico che questa giornata
[Musica]
la consapevolezza di non essere soli a
vedere
[Musica]
aero
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]